hahaha
yeah I've seen enough
send it shut him down
[Music]
hello Internet welcome to film Theory
the show that's been lost in the back
rooms for over a year now please send
help at this point I'm sure we all know
what the back rooms is right this
Creepypasta turned analog horror series
created by Indie filmmaker Kane pixels
absolutely took YouTube by storm last
year with its haunting Aesthetics its
mysterious story and its deep lore just
begging to be uncovered and that has
actually become a big part of the
franchise something that Kane talked
about in a recent interview with my
friend Anthony Padilla you have people
dissecting your videos you have the film
theorists I think they made like five
videos dissecting the back rooms as any
of their analyzes dictate where you take
your series no no hear that map Pat you
do not have any power over this man oh
is that so then why did your characters
follow my advice as I pointed out in a
recent YouTube short I'm not just coping
here am I yeah
thank you Matthew for all your coverage
but no sadly you do not influence the
series well poop but then again I can't
blame him what Kane's been doing with
the series so far has worked really well
well enough that it's caught the
attention of people well beyond our
little corner of Internet analog horror
yeah in case you didn't hear this one
Kane has actually teamed up with movie
studio a24 to make a feature-length big
budget adaptation of his back room
series with Kane himself directing that
right there that is a big deal 8 24 of
the people behind instant Classics like
everything everywhere all at once ex
machina the witch mid-summer hereditary
my first thought after hearing this news
whoa congratulations to Kane I am so
excited to see how this thing turns out
my second thought after hearing the news
though are they allowed to do this see
well Kane's series is really original in
and of itself it's based on a viral meme
Kane didn't come up with the original
idea of the back rooms and he's openly
admitted to that fact I was vaguely
aware of the back rooms I was aware of
it in terms of the original image and
the caption that I saw on Instagram two
years before so it got me to thinking
who actually owns the copyright to the
back room see this is an interesting
question because we don't actually know
who came up with the back rooms we know
when and where it was invented but not
who made it so the idea originated in a
threat on 4chan's paranormal themed X
image board on May 12 2019 asking users
to post images that felt off in some way
or another one reply posted this picture
of a large room with yellow wallpaper
which first appeared in another thread
back in 2018. someone else replied to
this image writing the caption that
would then go on to set the tone for the
entire idea of the back rooms from that
point forward the stink of old moist
carpet The Madness of mono yellow the
endless background noise of fluorescent
lights but here's the thing by default
all the 4chan's posters are Anonymous so
we have no idea who first posted the
image and who first wrote The caption so
the whole idea kinda just transcended
into internet Creepypasta folklore where
Kane eventually found it and then used
it as an inspiration for his own series
now all of that in and of itself is
really cool and it's made for an
incredible Community Driven writing
project as hundreds of people can
contribute to the lore of the back room
so the introduction of a film into the
mix by an actual oscar-winning movie
studio like a24 that right there that
changes things because the back rooms is
no longer the territory of the internet
Wild West it's now in a more traditional
setting and as Kane himself has pointed
out all of this unofficial unlicensed
content can start to become a problem in
like a normal film setting that would
just be copyright infringement that
would be the theft of Ip but on the
internet everyone owns everything even
if legally they don't he's definitely
not wrong this problem becomes a lot
more tricky when you realize that Kane's
series could qualify as the same sort of
unofficial unlicensed content so today I
want to dive into this issue and see if
we can work out what's what if those
original posts were in fact Anonymous
who actually owns the back rooms does
anyone own the back rooms and is Kane
series and this big budget movie all at
risk of copyright infringement is all of
this the end of the back rooms as we
know it put on your hazmat suits loyal
theorists because we're headed to the
most terrifying and endless Labyrinth of
them all copyright law before we get
started at this point I feel like it
goes without saying but just be clear I
am not a lawyer this is not legal advice
these are just the findings that I was
able to dig up during my research also
we're only going to be talking about
copyright law as it pertains to the US
not because other countries and their
laws are unimportant more because the
person Kane and the company a24 that
we're talking about here are in the U.S
cool cool so I think the first question
we need to answer here is can Anonymous
work be copyrighted I mean might be kind
of hard to just stroll down to the U.S
copyright office where to disguise and
then filling out some forms without
listing names right no actually you can
absolutely file for copyright protection
without filling in any sort of author's
name but even so you wouldn't need to in
the first place you don't actually need
to formally register a creative work
with government to get that copyright
protection you actually get that
protection the moment that your work is
created whether or not you're known to
be the creator of the work the highest
profile example of this in recent years
has got to be the anonymous graffiti
artist Banksy who defended their artwork
from being used by a greeting card
company by using the copyright
protection on said artwork now to be
fair this case happened over in Europe
but this sort of anonymous copyright
protection works exactly the same way in
the U.S we actually go into a lot of
detail about copyrights trademarks and
how films like Winnie the Pooh Blood and
Honey Are Disney's worst nightmare in
another video it's long and short of it
under the copyright term extension act
for an anonymous work anything created
in the US has copyright protection for
95 years after its first published for
120 years after its first creation
whichever comes first all of this
together then should mean bad news for
Kane in the back rooms movie right since
the original 4chan post was published in
2019 the copyright for it shouldn't
expire until 21-14 so that's the case
Kane might want to take down his videos
for the next couple of decades right
well maybe not we've established that
Anonymous works are protected by
copyright but our next question here is
whether or not this sort of 4chan post
can even be copyrightable in the first
place short answer yes long answer yeah
it's complicated copyright protects
original Works fixed in any tangible
medium of expression basically if you
make something original and creative you
own the copyright for it Book Movie
music architecture YouTube video or my
personal favorite pantomime now the bar
for originality and creativity are
pretty darn low in the eyes of the law
so the original picture from the back
room's absolutely qualifies whoever took
that picture of the room and posted it
to 4chan created the image so check
there for originality and they were
exercising some level of creativity in
the choice of the subject how it was
framed the choice to do it at a Dutch
angle Etc same thing for the separate
person who wrote The caption obviously
it's original insofar as they came up
with the ideas and they wrote them and
there's no denying that it's brimming
with creativity setting a bleak scene
and creating a captivating horror
scenario it also passes the bar and gets
copyright protection however even if the
picture and the text are separately
protected by copyright law it's
important to remember the scope of said
protection first of all even if it's
found that something is directly
violating the copyright of the posts
it's gonna be difficult for the original
authors to come forward with a case the
original 4chan posts have long since
been deleted along with any potentially
identifying information like IP
addresses and these authors are going to
have a difficult time proving that they
were the ones who originally made the
post secondly even if they could prove
their ownership it's probably not even
worth the legal hassle though you don't
lose copyright protection on your work
if you don't enforce that protection how
vigorously you protect your work is
factored into a Court's judgment on the
matter for example if you took a
photograph and wrote a caption for it
that was then widely circulated across
image boards YouTube Twitter and
dedicated fan wikis for years and you
never took any action until real money
came along yeah the judge is gonna take
that into consideration anything you
might win in Damages might not even be
enough to cover the legal fees thirdly
sure you can copyright individual works
but you can't copyright ideas just
because someone takes a picture of a
creepy room with fluorescent lights and
yellow wallpaper doesn't mean that
they're the only one with copyright to
that aesthetic and that no one can ever
take another picture of a creepy room
with fluorescent lights and yellow
wallpaper the copyright protection of
this original back room's photograph is
limited to this single photograph so
yeah if Kane wants to use this exact
specific image in his series or movie
sure that might be a problem but he
clearly hasn't done that he's created
entirely new imagery for his videos and
as for the text sure these two sentences
and the way that they express their
ideas are protected by copyright but the
ideas themselves they're not protected
even something specific like the word
back rooms which Kane took from the post
he used as the name of the series
wouldn't be protected here why well you
can't copyright names titles words or
short phrases that kind of stuff falls
under the domain of trademarks another
thing that we cover in more detail over
in that Winnie the Pooh video
additionally the word and idea of a back
room you know a room in the back of a
business or office or whatever has
existed long before that 4chan post so
it's not exactly something you could
just decide is yours because you took a
picture or thought of a spooky story
obviously Kane lifted the general Vibe
of the back rooms from the original
image and caption the yellow wallpaper
fluorescent light liminal spaces All
That Jazz he also took the general idea
of the back rooms being huge and full of
weird stuff and again just to clear up
any ambiguity here Kane admits that he
was very much inspired by the post I I
was vaguely aware of the back rooms or I
was aware of it in terms of the original
image and the caption that I saw on
Instagram two years before other than
that though not a whole lot of your
sticks plenty of ideas are reminiscent
of content from the original back rooms
post or the back rooms Wiki people in
Kane series fall into back rooms in a
way that seems visually similar to no
clipping but Kane has never once used
the word no clipping to describe that
process in his Canon sometimes strange
noises that sound like a party can be
heard in Kane's videos which could be a
reference to the party goers from the
Wiki's Canon
foreign
but again Kane has never brought the
actual party goers or their lore into
his world even ideas like the size of
the back rooms in Kane series aren't
one-to-one with the original post sure
Kane's back rooms are big but it's never
once specifically mentioned to be 600
million square miles like the original
post described it pretty much the only
things that Kane took from that original
post are the yellow Vibe the idea of
falling into and getting lost and the
words the back rooms most everything
else in these videos are entirely
original creations of Keynes the
organization async in their goals
project kv-31 and the portal into the
back rooms the bacteria monster my form
fellow life form fellow yeah sorry guys
we gotta update the wiki sorry the life
form fellow sure well anyway that was
still Kane's the long and short of it is
that he's more than in the clear to make
a film about the original story that
he's crafted but see Kane's not the
person I'm worried about in this episode
after all of this Research into
copyright law the quirks of anonymity
and who owns what in this circumstance
he's gonna be fine he's well within his
legal rights to partner with a24 and
make this movie and I'm excited to see
what comes of it no I'm more worried
about us you me and all those small
creators out there what concerns me now
is what that this movie is gonna mean
for the sorts of crowd-sourced online
horror stories that the back rooms
represents I fear that this could spell
disaster for these sorts of stories why
well because even if Kanan a24 are in
the clear to make their back rooms movie
they're likely going to want to protect
that film to the letter of the law now
don't misunderstand me I don't think
that Kane is going to be going after
people for making their own original
backrooms content I don't think he wants
to do that he has been nothing but a
kind and thoughtful guy every time that
we've interacted and even in that
interview with Anthony he explained his
thoughts on the whole communal ownership
of ideas thing on the internet everyone
owns everything even if legally they
don't it feels like you do and in
practice you do I don't have an issue
with that I like that that's a good
thing that right there that is a great
way to look at projects like the back
rooms no the problem here isn't gonna be
coming from Kane it's gonna be coming
from the studios see making the jump
from online video to Major Motion
Picture involves a lot of money a a lot
of money in budget sure but also in
potential returns from movie ticket
sales and merch merchandising where
they're real
S as of all time you'll see that the
Lions share their revenue actually comes
from the merch it's true for Pokemon
Star Wars Mickey Mouse Winnie the Pooh
Minecraft and if this back rooms movie's
a hit I could absolutely see this sort
of thing happening here too just imagine
Hazmat guy action figures life form
fellow plushies Kane may or may not be
interested in this part of the show
business but the Hollywood producers
he's working with definitely are and
that means that they're going to want to
protect their IP vigorously so they're
the ones making that money I mean this
exact scenario has happened before y'all
remember Slenderman he's a pillar of
online Creepypasta folklore and just
like the back rooms everyone felt like
they owned a part of Slenderman and at
the beginning things definitely operated
that way that's why you saw so many free
low budget Indie projects centered on
the Slenderman Slender the Eight Pages
Marble Hornets but once the idea of
Slenderman became a phenomenon and
caught the attention of larger media
companies when Real Money started to get
involved things changed Eric Knudsen the
original creator of Slenderman had to
step up to stop Shady low quality
content from destroying his idea they
became more involved in for-profit prod
projects like Slender the arrival and
eventually he sold the rights to the
character entirely to mythology
entertainment who went on to block
independent crowdfunded movies from
release and then made their own big
budget film with Sony pictures again I
cannot stress enough how much I don't
think Kane wants this to happen but when
you're dealing with Hollywood this sort
of stuff becomes inevitable what then do
we do here loyal theorists if the back
room's film is successful I don't want
there to be some sort of Gold Rush of
all these Major Movie Studios trying to
take their claim on any and every viral
Creepypasta and internet folklore does
anyone really want or need the EA funded
Jeff the Killer game a Universal Studios
Ben Drowned movie A Lavender Town
Netflix miniseries I don't think so
thankfully there are ways to protect
yourself your work and your favorite
content creators using the exact same
copyright laws that got us started down
this road in the first place first and
foremost if you create something and
post it online make sure you sign it
make sure that it's attributed to you
either with your real name or an online
Alias that you can prove is yours that
way people know that this was your work
from the second that you uploaded it it
is unambiguously yours and your creative
rights are protected by copyright I mean
that's why they're there after all might
as well put them to use and on top of
this make sure that you're posting to
platforms that respect those rights and
don't have anything shady hidden in
their end user license agreements that
somehow transfer any ownership of
content posted there to their website
you'd actually be surprised how many
fairly large websites have Clauses like
this that is really not cool next if you
can create your own characters and use
your own ideas obviously those will
always belong to you and no one's gonna
be able to use that content without your
approval that being said it can be
difficult so third if you do want to
build off of something that already
exists make sure that what you're
building off of is either in the public
domain or it's basic enough that what
you contribute will clearly be yours
what am I talking about well some of
it's obvious if you want to write
stories about ancient mythology folklore
fairy tales stuff like Thor or the Baba
Yaga or The Little Mermaid you are
almost certainly in the clear as long as
what you write isn't taken from other
modern interpretations of those same
ideas other things that you should be
good to use are urban legends and
Cryptids stuff like big foot Mothman
Bloody Mary no single person owns those
ideas and you could just make some
incredibly unique stories using them as
jumping off points this also applies if
you want to create something using basic
ideas to build off of like with the back
rooms take the same idea that Kane used
as the basis for a series and then build
your own ideas on top of it away from
canes you don't need to use async or
project kv-31 or the life form fellow to
tell a compelling story about the back
rooms all you gotta do is take an idea
that you like and change it enough that
it becomes your own thing great example
of this the Enderman from Minecraft they
were originally spoofs of Slenderman I
mean the name alone makes it pretty darn
obvious but over the years the Endermen
have had their own quirks and lore added
they've become completely unique from
their slender Origins you can do the
exact same thing using ideas that you
like and then changing them enough to
make them yours and yours alone so all
of that protects you and your work but
what if we want to protect the
collective Works stuff like the
incredible Community Driven lore that's
popped up around the back rooms well we
have the perfect template to look to
with the SCP Wiki if you somehow don't
know the SCP Foundation is a
collaborative writing project where
users submit articles about fictional
objects locations and characters all
inspired by elements of horror sci-fi
and urban fantasy a lot of this content
is similar in toned to the back rooms
once an article is approved to go up on
the website though anyone is free to
take the ideas from that article and add
it to their own work both on and off the
SCP website everything published on the
SCP Wiki is done through the Creative
Commons attribution sharealike 3.0
license or ccbysa for short that means
that anyone is free to make content
based on scps they can even make money
but they have to credit the original
authors and then also publish their work
under that same share alike license that
means that yes anyone from an indie Game
Dev to a major movie studio can profit
from the SCP Wiki in their articles that
the ideas that they add to the SCP must
also be free for anyone else to use
publish and profit from though this
might not work for everything this is an
awesome system for these sorts of
collaborative projects and maybe the
single most important thing to keep in
mind about all of this support the
independent writers and artists that you
love so they can keep creating read the
work of these creators share them with
your friends help spread the word one of
my particular favorites that I haven't
seen reach the same level of success as
the back rooms or SCP yet are the short
stories by the Reddit user search and
rescue woods they have a series about
these mysterious staircases just
appearing out in the woods and their
connections to missing persons it is
great remember the next back room
Slenderman and SCP Foundation is out
there somewhere just waiting to be
discovered so please share some of your
favorites down in the comments check out
what everyone else is posting down there
I know I'll be excited to see what you
guys are saying down there because who
knows maybe one day it'll appear here in
a theory till that day comes though
remember it's all just a theory a film
Theory and I know that I mentioned this
video a couple times in this episode but
if you want to learn more about
copyright and trademark and how it is
shaping the creative landscape as we
know it that Winnie the Pooh horror
movie episode is on the left it is a
very cool discussion about something
that is very scary to Disney right now
or if you're tired of legal stuff and
just want to catch up on the latest back
rooms lore our latest lore video is over
on the right as always my friends I'll
see you next week